[Music]
hi welcome to how to build Next Level
web applications with collabron
I'm Justin Mahood a product manager in
Google Cloud
hi I'm Sarah cord I'm a senior developer
relations engineer on Google Cloud
focusing on serverless
and today we're going to be talking
about Cloud run Cloud run allows you to
deploy and scale applications fast and
securely in a fully managed environment
it's simple and automated
there's no infrastructure to manage and
no cluster to worry about
and it allows you to go faster and as a
developer just be more productive
Cloud run Services automatically scale
their container instances Up and Down
based on incoming requests or events and
you only pay when your containers are
processing requests with Cloud run
Services you can build things like
public websites and apis using
server-side rendered Pages rest or
graphql apis or maybe streaming with
websockets
it's also great for internal Services
internal websites or apis or private
HTTP and grpc microservices
and finally it's great for data
processing workloads like processing
queue messages or at the center of an
event driven architecture
but few applications are just a
container particularly a web application
and that's why we've worked to make
Cloud run easy to integrate with the
rest of the gcp ecosystem
so let's break down a typical full stack
web application
first you've got a cloud run service
the compute to run your web server or
your API in a container
typically you need some kind of database
maybe Cloud SQL for a relational
database or firestore for a fully
managed document database depending on
your application you may also need a
cache layer or an in-memory database
such as redis using Cloud memory store
you may also need cloud storage for
storing status static assets or other
files
finally you want to host your
application at the domains of your
choice leverage CDN caching
or maybe even serve the front end from a
storage bucket our Global external load
balancer can help you there in
conjunction with Cloud CDN and Cloud
armor
and one great thing about using Cloud
run at the center of your web
application is how easy it is to use all
these components together
here are some of the ways Cloud run can
help improve your developer velocity
when building a web app like I just
described
so for example
for most Google cloud services like
firestore or cloud storage along with
many others you can consume them
seamlessly just by including their
client libraries in your code this just
works using Cloud runs per service
identity
Cloud run also offers built-in support
for cloud SQL connectivity and
Authentication
as well as tight Secrets manager
integration
and then when you're ready to deploy
our integration with Cloud build lets
you go from source to container in a
single command
you can even set up continuous delivery
from your git repository in just a few
clicks
however there are some scenarios where
the integration process is a bit more
complicated let's take using a redis
cache for example using Cloud memory
store our fully managed caching product
first you need a cloud memory store
instance sitting on a VPC Network
you need to make sure there's a
serverless VPC access connector that can
access the redis cache this allows Cloud
run to access VPC resources directly
and finally you need to configure your
Cloud run service to use the DPC
connector and make sure the connection
information for the cache is available
to your code via environment variables
now this is a bit more involved than
some of the other scenarios we just
talked about
and anytime we see creepy complexity
that's an opportunity to simplify the
developer experience
so we've improved this experience to
just be a few clicks or a single CLI
command using a feature called
Integrations which is now in preview let
me show you a quick exam
you'll now see an Integrations tab in
the detail page of your Cloud run
service from here you click add
integration and select redis
modify the name and the size as desired
and click deploy
congratulations you now have a redis
cache connected to your Cloud run
service
in addition to a few new resources being
created the redis cache and the vbc
connector your Cloud run service has
been automatically wired up to map the
correct environment variables and
networking settings all you have to do
is focus on writing your code
another scenario we've simplified is you
is configuring custom domains for your
Cloud run services using our Global
external load balancer the global load
balancer can be quite powerful as part
of your web application Beyond just
configuring domains for your Cloud run
service you can set path specific routes
you can control cache settings with
Cloud CDN or firewall rules with Cloud
armor but previously setting this up
with Cloud run has required nearly a
dozen steps and creating many networking
resources along the way
along the way we've created an
integration for this scenario as well
streamlining the process so you can
spend more time iterating on your code
let me show you an example of this one
back in the Integrations tab add another
integration
this time choose custom domains
enter the domain or the subdomain you
want to use for this service and then
like Cloud run handle the details you
can even add multiple entries for
different domains or even paths and
configure them just as simply
the only thing you need to do is
configure your DNS record you'll have an
SSL certificate provisioned
automatically
these new Integrations are designed to
help simplify complex patterns that are
common in applications particularly web
applications in keeping with our goals
of Simplicity Automation and always
focusing on improving developer velocity
just a few highlights
this is one command for complex
Integrations the Gratis and custom
domains using load balancing
IT wires up Cloud run for you with the
appropriate settings
gives you easy access to all of the
related resources and it's available in
the gcloud Run CLI as well as integrated
directly into the cloud run
comments
and now I'm going to hand it over to
Sarah Ford who's going to show you these
new features in action Sarah
thanks Dustin in this demo you will see
how you can use cloud run Integrations
to automatically create and configure a
redis in memory data store and a cloud
load balancing based custom domain
here is a small single page app using
vue.js running on localhost it keeps
track of the number of votes for dogs or
cats
I have redis running locally as an
in-memory data store
now I'm on team docs College Bulldogs
Turbo Dogs the blue dog
but then again my neighbor's cat is
pretty cool
and to keep the demo code short I'll
implement the exclusive or at a later
date
now in the code you can see I'm using
redis as a simple in-memory data store
to hold the vote counts you can see the
default redis host and Reddit support
environment variables here and our
express.js app which are used to connect
to redis
now in our routes in the get dogs route
you can see how I checked the status of
redis and return an error if redis isn't
available which you'll see later on
otherwise I just returned with redis
similarly in the post-dog's request to
vote
if redis is not available a return and
error otherwise I just increment the
count
for a front end I wrote a small BJs
single page app that you just saw which
is located alongside the express app for
purposes of this demo I'll use the same
Cloud run service to serve this
client-side app I can do this by
building the view JS app into a
distribution folder within my cats xor
dogs service which will serve it as
static files on the root route
as Justin mentioned earlier there are
numerous features that focus on
improving your developer velocity for
example you can use gcloud run deploy to
utilize Cloud build to go from source to
container to deployment in a single
command
I'll answer some questions for example
the location of the source code is in
the local directory
and they'll use this adjusted service
name cats X or a dog service by hitting
enter
I'll enable some apis needed for the
integration this is the first time I'm
running the integration on in this
project
I'll make the endpoints public since
this is an API and a single page app
now we'll wait for the container to be
built and deployed
at this point I did not have a redis
instance running Google Cloud I only had
a redis instance running locally so
voting on the site will not work
now that the service is deployed let's
open the viewjs web app
now we see that we do not have a redis
instance available
instead of going to Cloud memory store
for redis and creating the instance
manually you'll see me use the cloud run
integration feature Justin just
introduced to create the redis instance
on your behalf
so you can click the new integration Tab
and then click add integration to get
started
and you can just click redis
for the small app the default a one
gigabyte capacity looks good
and you are prompted to enable any
required apis for this integration
next you'll see the resources that will
automatically be created for you for
example the serverless VPC connector
will be created for you automatically
since Cloud run requires the connector
to talk to redis which is in a VPC
Network
please review the docs for the
additional costs for these two resources
let's hit submit to get started and
you'll get updates as resources are
created
we see our redis instance is now active
at the bottom for next steps you'll see
the two new environment variables these
are the same variable names you saw me
use earlier
and as part of the integration process
a new revision of our clavron service
was deployed
in this new revision you'll see the two
environment variables automatically
configured to use the new redis instance
so let me do a refresh
now that we're using a new redis
instance in Google Cloud the votes are
starting out at zero
since I was using the same environment
variables from my localhost development
adding the redis integration just worked
I did not have to make any additional
code changes
and thus the debate continues
now that we have redis connected let's
go back and see what else we can do with
Integrations
let's explore the option to create a
custom domain using a Google Cloud load
balancer a custom domain allows you to
reach your application with your
self-chosen domain name as opposed to a
run.app URL
a Google Cloud load balancer is super
powerful it gives you the ability to add
Cloud CDN in Cloud armor among other
features and you'll have more advanced
requests routing capabilities
setting up a Google Cloud load balancer
manually requires nearly a dozen steps
where you have to create several
networking resources along the way Cloud
run Integrations help simplify this
process here you can see this
integration is creating six resources
and wiring them together for you for
example the mapping table which tells a
router how to route your requests
to be clear you can still customize
these resources for your own needs our
goal is to help you get the job done
faster by automating all of these manual
tasks
once you click on ADD integration all
you need to provide is your domain name
and the integration suggests
for the default values that I direct all
requests to this domain to be sent to
this cloudron service which is hosting
my single page app
and that's it just hit submit
and to re-emphasize this is the same
process that you would follow to
configure it manually and you can still
edit the resources later this includes
the provisioning of a SSL certificate on
your behalf
Cloud run Integrations is choosing the
best defaults for using these products
with the cloud run service
now that you see the IP address is
available you can now go create your DNS
record
here I'm using Google domains and adding
an a record to this new IP address as
adjusted by the integration and note I'm
using a TTL of one minute for demo
purposes
now our integration is active and that
took about a little less than 10 minutes
for me
let's view the details of the
integration
and here you can see all the resources
that were deployed
and let's copy our domain name
and visit our site and cast our votes
as for next steps you now have the power
of a Google Cloud load balancer since
the integration provisioned it for you
for example you can control cache
settings with Cloud CDN and configure
firewall rules with Cloud armor even
though you saw me use cloud console you
can do everything that I showed today
using gcloud so let's use gcloud to
recap
you can view the list of current
Integrations
and you can describe an integration
for example custom domains and see the
SSL certificate has been provisioned
and this concludes the demo for clavron
Integrations
thanks Sarah and thanks to everyone for
watching our talk
if you want to learn more about using
Cloud run at the center of your web
application
and connecting to a variety of gcp
services including our new preview
feature of Integrations you can check
that out on public documentation Pages
for cloud run
thanks everyone
thanks
[Music]